What are your thoughts on cortical steroids, like flow days, nasal sprays, or allergies or steroid inhalers for asthma?
Um, management.
Well, again, I'm one of those functional doctors who believe that sometimes the use of medication is wise.
So, I don't think that it's healthy to take a dogmatic position against those things like all because they're medication.
I never want to use them.
But, I also think it's foolish to take a dogmatic position.
I don't want doctor to take this, or this seems to work for me.
So, I'm just going to keep taking it blindly without doing some research.
So, I think you have to have a balanced approach.
I think there's oftentimes a need for using cortical steroids.
Oftentimes, indeed, for using asthma medication on a daily basis.
Lots of times, it needs to be taking medication on a daily basis.
But if you're not asking deeper questions, like, why do I have asthma?
And I need to get to the bottom of this.
Then I think you're, that's, that's not wise at all.
So, I think we need to dig to find the causes of our disorders instead of thinking that we are the victim of some named disease.
Oh, I am asthma. My mom had asthma. My sister has asthma.
It runs into the family. Oh, does it?
Or do you all have a sensitivity because of a familial trait that you all lived in a multi-house?
Or that you all ate the same foods? Or what is it?
You've got to dig to the bottom of this.
So, finding out in case of asthma, it's very often healing the gutted, healing food sensitivities.
That is a key component of actually getting a person off of the long-term asthma medication.